A GREAT DAY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE APPARENT PIPE BOMBS HAVE
RECEIVED HUGE MEDIA ATTENTION IN
THE PAST FEW DAYS AND RIGHTLY
SO.
THE WHOLE THING IS HORRIFYING.
BUT THEY ARE NOT ISOLATED ACTS.
IT'S SUPPOSEDLY PART OF THE
LANDSCAPE IN THIS COUNTRY.
THREATS, ENVELOPES FILLED WITH
WHITE POWDER AND PHYSICAL
ATTACKS.
EVERY DAY, ARE MORE EXAMPLES OF
THIS.
THE DETAILS REMAIN SPARSE BUT
THE REACTION HAS BEEN
PREDICTABLE AND DEPRESSING.
YOU SEE THE USUAL DUMB PEOPLE ON
TELEVISION TO MAKE PARTISAN
POINTS OR BOOSTS CABLE NEWS
RATINGS AS THEY INVARIABLY DO,
AND AND THAT INCLUDES THE
PRESIDENT'S DISLIKE OF THE MEDIA
AND ACTIVE TERROR.
AND UP IT WENT ON LIKE THIS WITH
MAXIMUM SELF-RIGHTEOUSNESS.
>> THE PRESIDENT CANNOT ESCAPE
SCRUTINY.
>> PRESIDENT HAS SEEN FOR TWO
YEARS ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
TRYING TO DETOXIFY THE
ENVIRONMENT OR RATHER HELPED
POUR GASOLINE ON THE FIRE.
>> I BLAME THAT RHETORIC OUT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE THAT COMES FROM
THE TOP.
>> TO SAY NO CONNECTION BETWEEN
WHAT TRUMP HAS HAD BETWEEN
HILLARY CLINTON, BARACK OBAMA,
ERIC HOLDER, AND CNN, --
>> Tucker: OBAMA IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PIPE BOMBS
NOW, OVER AND OVER.
BUT THIS TIME STRANGELY AT
DIDN'T.
THEY DIDN'T SEEM TO CARE VERY
MUCH, MAYBE THEY JUST EXPECTED
IT'S COMING.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED BACK TO
THE MEDIA, AND BLAMED THEM FOR
MAKING AMERICA ANGRY.
THE CROWD SHOUTED, LOCK HER UP.
AND IT WAS, IT IS ALL NORMAL
NOW.
THE TWO PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
THAT DESPISE EACH OTHER SO MUCH,
THERE IS NOTHING THAT ONE CAN'T
IMAGINE THE OTHER DOING
INCLUDING ACTS OF TERRORISM.
THIS IS OMINOUS, WE ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO HATE OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS THIS MUCH.
THE QUESTION IS, HOW DID WE GET
HERE?
OUR LEADER MADE A SERIES OF
TERRIBLE DECISIONS AND NEVER
APOLOGIZE FOR THEM.
THE MIDDLE-CLASS DIED AND NOBODY
NOTICED.
NEW TECHNOLOGIES WERE SUPPOSED
TO UNITE US BUT INSTEAD DROVE US
FURTHER APART.
A ROTTEN EDUCATION SYSTEM,
DISINTEGRATING FAMILIES,
SHOCKING RATES OF SUBSTANCE
ABUSE, ALL OF THOSE PLAYED A
ROLE AND THERE WERE OTHER
FACTORS, TOO.
BUT MORE THAN ANYTHING, OUR
THINKING CHANGED.
THAT'S WHAT REALLY HAPPENED.
OVER TIME WE STOPPED DEBATING
POLITICS, ISSUES AND IDEAS AND
STARTED ATTACKING EACH OTHER FOR
THINGS THAT WE CAN'T CHANGE FOR
WHO WE ARE.
TAKE IMMIGRATION.
20 YEARS AGO WE WOULD BE ARGUING
ABOUT HOW MANY MIGRANTS TO ADMIT
INTO THIS COUNTRY, UNDER WHAT
CIRCUMSTANCES, WHETHER OR NOT IT
WAS ALL GOOD FOR AMERICA.
NONE OF THAT IS SERIOUSLY UNDER
DISCUSSION TODAY.
INSTEAD, WE GET MOMENTS LIKE
THESE.
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE IS A
SIN AGAINST GOD.
I BELIEVE THAT.
>> IF THE OF ALL PEOPLE AS MADE
THE COUNTRY NOT TO CLAMOR FOR
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS DOING
TO END.
>> THOSE WHO SELECTIVELY USE THE
BIBLE TO JUSTIFY THIS CRUELTY
ARE IGNORING A CENTRAL TENET OF
CHRISTIANITY.
SAID, SUFFER THE LITTLE CHILDREN
UNTO ME.
HE DID NOT SAY, LET THE CHILDREN
SUFFER.
>> Tucker: A A SIN AGAINST
GOD.
WHAT YOU ARE HEARING IS NOT
POLITICAL DEBATE.
IT IS THEOLOGY.
IT'S NOT BASED IN REASON, BUT IN
SOMETHING DEEPER, SOMETHING LESS
PREDICTABLE AND MORE FEROCIOUS.
IT IS A RELIGIOUS ARGUMENT,
THOSE ARE NOT RESOLVABLE WHICH
IS WHY YOU ARE TOLD NOT TO START
THEM AT THE DINNER TABLE.
RELIGIOUS DISPUTES PUSH PEOPLE
INTO EXTREMISM.
IF I THINK YOUR IDEAS ARE WRONG,
I'M HAPPY TO ARGUE WITH YOU
ABOUT THEM BUT IF I DECIDE YOU
ARE EVIL, I MAY BE TEMPTED TO
HURT YOU, IF ONLY IN
SELF-DEFENSE.
POLITICS LIKE THIS ISN'T REALLY
POLITICS, IT'S SECRETARY IS    S
POLITICS, IT'S SECRETARY IS    C
POLITICS, IT'S SECRETARY IS    E
POLITICS, IT'S SECRETARY IS    A
POLITICS, IT'S SECRETARY IS    Y
POLITICS, IT'S SECRETARY IS    I
POLITICS, IT'S SECRETARY IS    S
POLITICS, IT'S SECRETARY IS    H
POLITICS, IT'S SECRETARY IS    M
POLITICS, IT'S SECRETARY IS    .
WE INVITED BETO OVER WORK ONTO
THE TO DISCUSS WHETHER
HEALTH CARE IS AVAILABLE TO
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
BUT, HE COULDN'T EVEN SEE THE
OTHER SIDE, HE SAW ONLY
CALLOUSNESS AND SIN, WATCH.
>> I THINK THERE IS AN INTEREST
IN MAKING SURE THAT IF SOMEONE
IS GOING TO BE SICK, IF SOMEONE
NEEDS HELP, THAT WE DELIVER IN
THE MOST EFFICIENT AND
COST-EFFECTIVE WAY POSSIBLE.
>> YOU CAN PAY FOR IT IN THE
EMERGENCY ROOM.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT NOT
PAYING FOR IT AT ALL?
>> WILL THEN YOU CAN WATCH
PEOPLE DIE IN YOUR EMERGENCY
ROOM.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
BETO O'ROURKE IS NOT STUPID BUT
HE HAS DEVELOPED A HABIT OF MIND
THAT LEAVES NO ROOM FOR A
LEGITIMATE DISAGREEMENT WITH HIS
OWN VIEWS.
IF YOU ARE OPPOSED TO PAYING FOR
HEALTH CARE FOR ILLEGAL ALIENS
AND YOU ARE IN FAVOR OF WATCHING
PEOPLE DIE, YOUR MORALLY
CORRUPT.
WHY WOULD ANYONE WASTE TIME
TRYING TO REASON WITH A MONSTER
LIKE THAT?
WOULD YOU DEBATE HUMAN RIGHTS
WITH IDI AMIN?
OF COURSE NOT.
FACTS ARE IRRELEVANT.
AS CHARACTER AND MOTIVES ARE ALL
THAT MATTER.
SO WATCH THIS EXCHANGE WITH
CONGRESSMAN ALEX      ADAM SCHIF
CONGRESSMAN ALEX      ADAM SCHI.
WE KNOW THAT RUSSIA HACKED
JOHN PODESTA'S EMAIL ACCOUNT
DURING THE ELECTION.
HE MIGHT BE THE PERSON WHO HAS
THE ANSWER TO THAT, HE'S THE
RANKING DEMOCRAT ON THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE.
WATCH HOW HE RESPONDED.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU LOOK INTO
THE CAMERA AND SAY, I KNOW FOR A
FACT THAT VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS
BEHIND THE HACKS?
>> I KNOW ABSOLUTELY.
NOT ONLY IN THE UNITED STATES
BUT ALSO IN EUROPE.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU
ARE DODGING -- LOOK AND SAY, I
KNOW THEY HACKED IT.
>> I THINK RONALD RONALDE
>> I THINK RONALD RONALDG
>> I THINK RONALD RONALDN
>> I THINK RONALD RONALDW
>> I THINK RONALD RONALDU
>> I THINK RONALD RONALDD
BE ROLLING OVER IN HIS GRAVE --
>> Tucker: YOU ARE -- YOU
CAN'T SAY THEY HACKED --
>> YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE TO MOVE
YOUR SHOW TO RUSSIAN TELEVISION.
>> Tucker: IN OTHER WORDS,
SCHIFF REPLIED, I DON'T CARE
WHAT YOU ARE ASKING.
THE QUESTION IS, WHY YOU ARE
ASKING.
AND THE ANSWER OF COURSE IS,
BECAUSE YOU ARE A BAD PERSON AND
IN THIS CASE A TRAITOR TO YOUR
COUNTRY.
MOST POLITICAL CONVERSATIONS
LOOK LIKE THIS.
WHEN WE DEFEAT SOMEONE, WE KNOW
LONGER ARGUE AGAINST WHAT WE
BELIEVE.
WE WAIT UNTIL THEY MAKE A
MISTAKE, AND THERE IS NO
FORGIVENESS.
THE POINT IS NOT TO MAKE THINGS
RIGHT OR IMPROVE ANYTHING, THE
POINT IS TO VANQUISH AN ENEMY.
SO LOCK HER UP AND CRIMINAL
GUILT IS FOR COURTS AND JUDGES
TO DECIDE.
AND WHAT ABOUT THIS?
THE REVEREND JOHN KASICH WHO IS
THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OF OHIO,
WATCH WHEN YOU DISAGREE WITH
HIM, YOU ARE REALLY DISAGREEING
WITH GOD.
>> WE HAVE GOT TO START PUTTING
OURSELVES INTO THE SHOES OF
OTHER PEOPLE.
WE HAVE GOT TO START THINKING
ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCES THAT
OTHERS SUFFER, AND IF WE HAVE
BEEN SPARED THOSE BY THE GRACE
OF GOD, LET US BE APPRECIATIVE.
LET US COUNT OUR BLESSINGS AND
LET US REACH OUT TO THOSE WHO
HAVE THE LESS, AND LET'S STOP
PUTTING UP WALLS AROUND
OURSELVES AND NOT UNDERSTANDING
THE PLIGHT, THE TROUBLE IN THE
PROBLEMS OF OTHERS.
IT IS NOT RIGHT AND THE LORD
DOESN'T WANT IT, AND OUR PEOPLE
AT THEIR HEARTS WANT TO REACH
OUT TO OTHERS.
LOOK WHAT THEY DO IN THESE
STORMS, THEY GO AND RISK PEOPLE
THEY DON'T KNOW.
THEY PUT THEM IN THEIR HOMES AND
FEED THEM, THAT'S AMERICA.
>> Tucker: THE LORD DOESN'T
WANT IT, SAYS PASTOR K  .
WELL WHAT'S EASY TO KNOW AND
FORESEE IS, THE PEOPLE IN POWER
CLAIM MORAL AUTHORITY THEY DON'T
HAVE IN ORDER TO COMPEL YOU TO
OBEY.
WHAT HAPPENS?